[Musique]
bonsoir ben soit merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france ce soir lors
tout d'abord quelques impressions sur
l'atmosphère qui règne aux états unis
avec l'ouverture de ce procès est ce que
c'est le feuilleton que tout le monde va
suivre
en l'absence à l'heure précise de donald
trump qui a préféré se rendre à davos
je pense que ça va être le feuilleton le
plus ennuyant qu'on puisse imaginer en
raison parce que nous savons déjà
comment cela va se terminer en fin de
compte se rendra compte que les
républicains et le sénat américains ne
vont pas considérer le président
coupable de cet appui pouvoir et de
cette entrave au congrès et ils vont la
quitter en fin de compte il serait
presque impossible qu'il y ait une autre
issue la véritable question devient donc
quelles seront les événements entre
temps avant d'arriver à cette conclusion
que tout le monde connaît la réalité
c'est qu'on ne sait même pas ce qui va
arriver
mitch mcconnell le chef du sénat le
dirigeant de la majorité déjà mises en
place la possibilité de mettre un terme
au procès avec un vote et qu'il est prêt
donc si ils perdent le contrôle si des
témoins sont appelés qu'il n'aime pas
s'il décide de mettre un terme au procès
il le peut immédiatement
donc il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
surprises car il a mis en place des
garde fous pour s'en assurer
alors il y aura pas beaucoup de
surprises et vous prédisez un feuilleton
pas très intéressant il n'empêche
est-ce que selon vous il pourrait quand
même y avoir un impact sur la
présidentielle si l'on apprend peut-être
deux trois choses qui pourrait ne pas
plaire vraiment au peuple américain ça
vous semble possible
je pense que c'est très peu probable
il est très peu probable que nous
apprenons quelque chose de nouveau
lorsque la chambre des représentants a
introduit ses chefs d'inculpation les
démocrates qui étaient en contrôle ont
essayé de déterminer si le président
avait commis des crimes mais voilà ce
que cela pas de vraiment étonnant pour
la première fois de l'histoire des états
unis nous commençons un procès en
destitution au sénat sans avoir de
véritables chefs d'inculpation de
véritables crimes l'entravent au congrès
et l'abus de pouvoir sont les deux chefs
d'inculpation mais ce ne sont pas des
crimes public l'auditoire eux le peuple
américain a déjà a pris ses décisions
certains démocrates ont déjà à leur
propre vision pense que le président a
tort des républicains parce que le
président a raison à cela ne va pas
changer les indépendants qui sont encore
dans la terre maman pense que la
procédure est fausse qu'au niveau de la
chambre c'est elle et c'était les
démocrates qui a buzzé de la procédure
est maintenant au niveau du sénat et les
républicains
les deux parties sont malhonnêtes ne
disent pas la vérité
pour beaucoup d'américains il n'y a plus
aucun d'intérêt pour le procès alors
justement oui les démocrates a accusé
les républicains de vouloir organiser un
procès en destitution je cite truqués de
donald trump 1 au sénat avec un
calendrier imposé distille pourra
quitter au plus vite le président des
états unis est ce que c'est le cas quand
même effectivement qui veulent se
débarrasser de cela plus rapidement
possible l'une des questions c'est de
savoir s'il y aura des témoins et cela
fait partie de ces
événement qui pourrait ne pas arriver du
tout et ne poser aucun problème les
sénateurs évoque l'idée de témoins les
démocrates donne une liste de témoins
tels que l'ancien ambassadeur le
l'ancien secrétaire d'état aux affaires
de sécurité john bolton but ne va ni le
chef de cabinet de la maison blanche
ils veulent que ces personnes mais on a
déjà dit qu'ils ne pourront pas témoigné
républicains disent eh bien si vous
appelez c'était moi nous voulons
interroger et joe biden et son fils
hunter byetone qui sont au centre de
cette affaire de coups de téléphone au
président de l'ukraine
les démocrates ne veulent pas que c'est
thème on parle donc il y à un débat sur
qui appelait qui viendra mais on
certaines personnes disent qu'il n'y
aurait peut-être pas du tout de témoins
donc en fin de compte ce que le sénat
veut c'est que cette situation soit
résolue aussi vite que possible parce
que les républicains pensent qu'ils ont
déjà gagné
il était donc rade sont allés trop loin
et le public ne les suit pas et les
sondages semblent indiquer cela le
public n'est pas très intéressé par
cette procédure de destitution
mais en même temps à un sondage tout
récent indique que 57 % les américains
disent que toute preuve de la chambre
des représentants devrait être présenté
lors du procès parce que il semblerait
que le sénat ne permettrait même pas de
nouvelles preuves
la situation est si partisane qu'aucun
des partis des considéré comme étant
francs et on ne sait pas à qui faire
confiance
est ce que c'est pour cette raison que
vous nous décrivez que finalement donald
trump lui il semble très sûr de lui il
est partir à davos avec toujours le même
discours
une farce une chasse aux sorcières
on se souvient qu'à l'époque ans n'était
pas du tout la même chose mais bill
clinton lui s'était excusé il avait dit
qu'il était désolé
donald trump s'est pas du tout la même
zik un ski la raison finalement que
donald trump qu'on apprécie ou non est
certainement très bien très bon très
doué s'agissant de contrôler les médias
et de contrôler son image
bill clinton a menti sous serment et
effectivement il s'était excusé pour
cela ils espéraient et susciter
l'empathie tuna troll tu as construit
toute sa présidence sur sur sa volonté
sans honte de dire je ne m'excuse pour
rien je suis un homme qui force et je ne
m'excuse jamais finale trucks en allant
à davos est très stratégique
il parle de l'économie américaine il
parle aux autres dirigeants américains
il
c est l âge de son manque d'inquiétude
il ne veut surtout pas qu'à washington
on le pense inquiets de ce qui pourrait
se passer au cours de ce procès il veut
montrer qu'il n'a aucune inquiétude et
qui n'a rien à craindre car il n'a rien
fait de mal voilà ce qu'il dit je pense
que c'était une décision intelligente de
contraste et davos et ce qui se passe au
sénat parce que si donald trump semble
faire son travail pour le peuple et d'un
cela va à l'encontre de ce qui se passe
à washington
merci beaucoup ben swan journée les
investigations d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ce soir pour notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur merci à vous